so last week I created a video called
zoom versus Skype versus WebEx and you
know what it did really really well but
ever since I put that video out a few
things have changed
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is Dave
atomic welcome back to the channel if
you haven't been paying attention to the
media lately or have been concerned
about the covert 19 pandemic you've
probably missed the information
basically what I released last week
isn't entirely accurate and the best
information anymore since there's been a
huge up rise in number of users on zoom'
Skype and WebEx there's also been a
number of floors found in all of these
programs and in particular zoom has
copped most of the criticism many zoom
private chats have been completely
crashed by randoms some people are
reporting nudity pornography racial
abuse sexual harassment all sorts of
different things in these conversations
and video conferences that were meant to
be completely private now this is very
concerning especially if you're trying
to do this for a professional purpose
incorporate it into your business or if
you're using it as a learning experience
with kids and to add to all that drama
it also has been sending private data to
Facebook marketing so they can retarget
you with all sorts of different
campaigns this might not be a big deal
to some people but to others it's a
complete marketing lie because zoom
establishes an end-to-end encryption
which they've come out and said actually
is impossible with the zoom network as
it currently stands but obviously with
all this popularity and their shares
going from 70 US dollars a share to 150
US dollars a share doubling in over two
weeks that means a lot of little bugs
and loopholes are going to be found in
the software now I'm definitely one for
constructive criticism feedback and
making software better so I do actually
applaud zoom in this video for taking
the time to step into the light and go
yes we made a mistake and yet
we will fix it and we have fixed it as
of the 5th of April zoom is now
incorporating password-protected
conversations and conference calls there
also including waiting rooms where you
can specifically go through see who's
wanting to join your conversation and
kick them out if you don't recognize the
name now all of these features were
previously accessible and zoom but they
weren't activated by default for most
people they aren't looking into the
settings when they try and set up a
quick conversation with somebody so this
is what's resulted in zoom trolling zoom
has also come out publicly and stated
that they are no longer sharing their
analytics with Facebook marketing teams
so now your privacy and your security is
a lot more safe it still isn't
end-to-end encrypted which basically
means when you start a conversation it
goes through zoom and outer zoom with
nobody having access to it whatsoever
including exhume themselves whereas
unfortunately this encryption still
isn't there and other people can somehow
access your conversations if you aren't
vigilant another piece of information
that came to light as of the 4th of
April is Skype no longer requires an
account to join the conversation so
previously you needed to sign up to
Skype to join a conversation and that
was one of the reasons I said Skype
wasn't as good as zoom but now that
they've incorporated that feature it's
given them another leg up in the game so
now if you've been thrown off from zoom
because of all this controversy well
that's alright because there's plenty of
alternatives out there that are worth
looking at especially if you're looking
for just one-on-one conversations so for
everybody that owns an Apple device an
iPad an iPhone or anything of the sort
you can easily just use FaceTime
FaceTime has been a globally loved
feature for many years now and it is
very simple to use the best thing is
FaceTime is a hundred percent end-to-end
encrypted with Apple stating not even
they can view any of the conversation or
Khan
station history so if you're looking for
a very private conversation this is
definitely one way to go if you're
looking to have a one-on-one
conversation with somebody that's even
more secure signal is an alternative to
whatsapp that is perfect for more
private one-on-one media conversations
you also have the option of Skype and
Microsoft teams now I talked about Skype
and all its features in the last video
where I compared to the zoom and to
WebEx and it is definitely a good
platform to use if you're looking for
video conversations and chats but again
unfortunately Skype is not enter and
encrypted if this is a feature you're
worried about it's definitely not
something to look at and finally I want
to recommend Google duo I started using
Google duo for my personal phone calls
with my parents who live overseas in
another country with the internet being
exceptionally terrible in their
situation at the moment and pretty poor
in my situation as well
Google joy still holds up decently at
times where other apps have failed
completely so from a performance point
of view it does really well it also has
the ability to stream in 4k if you have
those capabilities but the best thing
about Google geo is it's built kind of
for a more family connected lifestyle
you can hold up to 12 people on a video
conference and yes it is a hundred
percent end-to-end encrypted for your
safety and security and that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this soon
vs. the world video and got a little bit
of information out of it if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
20:20 style next Monday I will be
announcing the winner of my giveaway
which was a couple videos back I'll link
it up here if I remember but if I don't
as always I'll see you next Monday